well some students in the clark county
school district still haven't met their
teacher or started classes these are a
few of the issues familiar with the
nevada learning academy that people are
facing they offer full-time distance
education kate houston in the newsroom
to break down the influx of students and
how the school is working to fix these
problems
yes brian denise nearly 7 000 students
are enrolled at the learning academy
1500 of those students have registered
in the past two weeks now the school is
trying to juggle growing enrollment
numbers and growing staff shortages and
although school started more than two
weeks ago tiffany netter says her son
jahan just started classes today jahan
has autism and an individualized
education plan and she's worried these
students are slipping through the cracks
other parents have taken to social media
to complain about a lack of teachers or
not being able to reach the school in an
email to parents last night principal
michael martin says they're considering
adding an afternoon elementary school
martin says this would cut class sizes
and help them hire more staff neder is a
bit skeptical you have to have so many
people that are going to be interested
you know saying and then if the teachers
come it's always just like a ripple
effect you don't know if the teacher is
going to work out it's just one thing
after another
in an email last week principal martin
says part of the reason for the staffing
shortages is the condensed timeline
while other ccsd schools receive
projected enrollment numbers months
ahead of time the learning academy had a
rapid increase in enrollment just over
the past few weeks and despite the
staffing challenges the principal says
they do not have plans to stop
enrollment adding that it's too big of a
demand for distance learning they are
asking for patience as they work to get
students their schedules and teachers
back to you